zone Europe sur sensation
bonsoir et bienvenue dans zones sur
Radio sensation et sur TV 78 nous sommes
à Hanovre en bassacre cette ville est
jumelée avec Rouen en Seine-Maritime
vous pouvez d'ailleurs écouter Radio
sensation Normandie saine en DAB+ et
radio sensation Normandie en FM sur
93.4 les jumelage il en sera notamment
en question avec nos invités dans cette
émission et de l'importance de
l'engagement citoyen en faveur de la
coopération franco-allemande nous
intéresserons également aux relations
franco-allemandes et à ce qui pousse les
Français et les Français à venir
s'installer ici en Allemagne pour
travailler ou pour étudier il sera aussi
question d'éducation aux médias puisque
nous vous ferons découvrir une
télévision locale qui informe et qui
forme et puis nous vous réserverons
également quelques surprises cette
émission spéciale est réalisée avec le
soutien du fond citoyen franco-allemand
à l'occasion de la journée
franco-allemande et du 60e anniversaire
du Traité de l'Elysée d'ailleurs ce
traité de l'Elysée en quoi consiste-t-il
élément de réponse tout de suite en
moins d'un siècle la France et
l'Allemagne se sont opposés durant trois
conflits majeurs la guerre
franco-prussienne de 1870 la Première
Guerre mondiale de 1914 à 1918 et la
Seconde Guerre mondiale de 1939 à 1945
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale et ce
pour éviter un énième conflit majeur
entre les deux nations la France et
l'Allemagne décident de se réconcilier
en signant le 22 janvier 1963 le traité
de l'Élysée
ce traité est aussi le fruit du
rapprochement entre deux hommes le
chancelier West allemand Conrad adénauer
et le président de la République
française Charles de Gaulle tous deux
c'était opposés au régime nazi et
c'était désormais tendre la main à
l'adversaire d'hier avec ce traité les
deux signataires ont décidé d'instaurer
une nouvelle relation afin de celluler
une amitié durable pour les signataires
il était important que ce traité ne
reste pas un simple document entre les
chefs d'État mais bien un traité où les
citoyens des deux pays soient impliqués
afin d'apprendre à se connaître à se
parler et à se comprendre
une des réussites de ce traité c'est
d'avoir suscité un fort rapprochement
entre les deux peuples une amitié ce qui
s'est concrétisée par la signature de
plus de 2300 jumelages et une centaine
d'initiatives citoyennes concernant
l'éducation et la Genèse le traité
pousse les deux pays à prendre des
mesures afin de favoriser
l'apprentissage de l'allemand mais aussi
du français il paraît évident pour les
deux états que l'apprentissage de la
langue du voisin est essentiel à une
cohabitation durable et dans la paix
en 2019 soit 56 ans après la signature
du document à l'Élysée un nouvel accord
a été signé par Emmanuel Macron et
Angela Merkel il complète le premier en
créant notamment de nouveaux liens
culturels et en matière de sécurité cet
accord est aujourd'hui connu sous le nom
de le traité de Aix-la-Chapelle
[Musique]
zone Europe avec le soutien du fond
citoyen franco-allemand je suis
maintenant avec goodrone 7 et Silvia
clean Borg bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous faites tous les deux
parties donc de la partie allemande du
comité du melage entre la ville de Rouen
et la ville de Hanovre ambassacs en
Allemagne un jumelage qui a vu le jour
en 1966 alors comment est-ce que la
ville de Rouen est la ville d'hanov se
sont rapprochés pour former ce jumelage
en tant que je sache on a créé le
jumelage entre
nos villes par le 2 mai
c'était encore un époque où les
gouvernements allemands a fait des
efforts de se rapprocher un peu plus au
pays voisins vous savez que la situation
après la guerre était encore bien
hostile
envers l'Allemagne et c'est parce que le
traité de lisait a été une idée géniale
pour
la situation après la guerre
et pour la l'amitié franco-allemande
jusqu'à ces jours alors justement
jumelage entre Rouen et Hanovre il a vu
le jour 3 ans après le traité de
l'Élysée qui a été signé le 22 janvier
1963 entre la France et l'Allemagne ils
posent les bases de l'amitié aujourd'hui
franco-allemande on appelle cela comme
ça aujourd'hui pour rapprocher pas
seulement les institutions mais aussi
les citoyens entre la France et
l'Allemagne des jumelages ont donc été
mis en place comme celui entre Rouen et
Hanovre il y en a aujourd'hui plus de
2200 partout entre la France et
l'Allemagne est-ce que vous estimez que
c'est encore important aujourd'hui en
2020 en 2023 d'avoir tous ces jumelages
c'est une bonne question au début de mes
activités dans ce métier je mets aussi
creuser la tête si le jumelage serait
peut-être en train de disparaître mais
maintenant à mon gré c'est pas du tout
je suis vraiment convaincu et qui le
commence une vraie naissance du jumelage
le jumelage d'aujourd'hui
n'est pas plus encore en concurrence
avec le tourisme classique au contraire
le jumelage et devenu une expérience
très intensive très touchant beaucoup
plus que on voyage dans le cadre de
tourisme individuel ou organisé et pour
nous
en offre et à Rouen c'est un défi et
aussi en plaisir de chercher en mode
approprié pour une réalisation
des deux villes quel est le programme
lorsque les roanais viennent visiter
Hanovre qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'ils
viennent découvrir
[Musique]
en avril et nous avons fait beaucoup des
pensées d'avant parce que nous voulons
faire une autre format autre voyage oui
et nous voulons pas faire une toute tous
les tous les tous les choses avec toute
la groupe nous avons partagé la croûte
en deux dans très un petit groupe et ça
c'était très
ça c'était mieux pour se faire connaître
pour faire des rencontres avec un ou
deux on peut parler ensemble et pas tous
avec la groupe qui était une forme
c'était très
marchait bien et quand vous vous rendez
à Rouen c'était quand la dernière fois
que vous êtes rendu en normandie
qu'est-ce que vous a le plus marqué dans
cette ville de Rouen
c'est moi qui j'étais à Rouen deux fois
avec le conseil de à nouveau et nous
avons visité le Kinder
les écoles maternelles et pour moi
j'étais une professeur pour moi c'était
très intéressant comment les écoles en
français marchent et après on avait
visité le marché de Noël à la cathédrale
et
on a fait beaucoup de
randonnées autour de
Rouen c'était très intéressant pour moi
et pour finir est-ce que l'année 2023
réserve de nouveau projet en ce qui
concerne le jumelage entre Rouen et
Hanovre
voyage à Rouen en avril de cette année
mais en plus j'ai une idée pour le futur
à part du jumelage annuel il s'agit de
rencontres thématiques pour quelques
jours seulement et pour une un type un
très petit groupe des où on est et de en
ouvrière par exemple une excursion sur
les vestiges de l'ancien frontières
entre les deux parties de l'Allemagne le
long de la rivière Elbe en combination
avec un séjour à Berlin pour visiter les
restes du mur ou le centre français
et ça c'est bien possible dans le cadre
du jumelage bien qu'il se déroule dans
un autre lieu merci beaucoup goodrum et
Sylvia d'avoir été avec nous dans dans
zone Europe je que vous faites partie de
la partie allemande du comité jumelage
entre la ville de Rouen et la ville
d'Avre
[Musique]
zone Europe avec le soutien du faon
citoyen franco-allemand je suis
maintenant avec Laurence Belland bonjour
bonjour vous êtes la vice-présidente de
l'association Le Carrefour Hanovre
accueil l'association qui accueille et
qui aide les Français qui viennent
s'installer ici dans cette ville d'anov
alors en général pourquoi est-ce que les
Français viennent ici s'installer je
pense qu'il y a plusieurs raisons mais
je crois que la raison la plus
importante est au niveau professionnel
très souvent les entreprises proposent
des échanges avec des entreprises
allemandes de deux ou trois ans pour
connaître la façon de travailler en
Allemagne alors justement à neuf c'est
une ville de plus de 500 000 habitants
capital de la bassak est-ce que c'est
une ville qui a une forte communauté
étrangère ou bien c'est une ville très
allemande ah non c'est une ville je
dirais presque internationale elle est
connue justement pour son école de
musique qui est intéressante pour
beaucoup beaucoup de personnes par
exemple les Japonais et les Chinois et
ensuite il y a l'université de médecine
et là ils viennent du monde entier pour
se spécialiser dans leur domaine de
médecine et il y en a énormément de tous
les pays je pourrais pas tous vous les
énoncer alors sur la Communauté
française maintenant plus précisément
est-ce qu'on sait quelles sont les
principales raisons qui poussent les
Français à choisir Hanovre pour
s'installer en Allemagne je pense
qu'ils a fini avec l'Allemagne et puis
une fois qu'on a connu la ville et qu'on
a vu comment on y vit on aime et les
Français je pense qu'il cherche un petit
peu de liberté de sportivité aussi si
c'est assez intéressant et une fois
qu'ils en ont goûté un petit peu
ils dressent il reste tout simplement et
ils en profitent alors si on se penche
maintenant sur votre cas personnel plus
précisément pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez choisi de vous installer ici dans
cette ville de neuve alors tout
simplement je j'ai commencé à faire de
l'allemand au lycée et j'ai adoré et on
nous a proposé un échange scolaire entre
Rouen et Hanovre je suis de Rouen oui et
je suis venu en 1993 et je vous avoue
que j'ai pratiquement pas parlé allemand
pendant deux semaines j'étais trop
timide mais j'ai je suis rentrée à Rouen
et j'ai décidé je reviendrai cette ville
est formidable je suis revenue et je
suis restée ce qu'il y a d'autres pays
européens qui sont représentés ici à
Hanovre oui alors il y a des échanges
scolaires et des échanges aussi avec des
adultes avec la Pologne par exemple
l'Angleterre aussi on le voit beaucoup
on le voit aussi à l'hôtel de ville vous
avez toutes les drapeaux de tous ces
pays européens je vous conseille d'aller
le voir c'est sympa alors un offre si on
regarde sur une carte c'est un peu au
centre de l'Allemagne au centre de
l'Europe même on pourrait le dire
d'ailleurs est-ce que c'est un petit peu
pour ça que l'association s'appelle le
carrefour à Nord accueil alors au moment
où le carrefour a été fondé je n'étais
pas ça c'est il y a un peu plus de 40
ans mais je pense que c'était ça c'était
un endroit central où se retrouver
Hanovre et les Français trouvent
chercher un carrefour ou se retrouver et
parler ensemble voilà un œuf c'est une
ville je crois 13 sportive il y a
beaucoup de choix pour pratiquer tous
les sports qu'on aime ah oui alors il y
a des pistes cyclables partout il y a
des terrains de sport partout il y a un
grand club de foot aussi on peut faire
beaucoup de choses on peut faire des
promenades aussi il y a il y a tout ce
qu'il faut et il y a le lac où on peut
faire le tour en courant ou en marchant
il y a la grande forêt il y a le canal
on peut se promener partout et faire du
sport partout alors je l'ai dit au début
de cette interview là des principales
objectifs de donc l'association Le
Carrefour à neuvre accueil c'est
d'accueillir les Français qui viennent
ici quels sont leurs principales
demandes leur principal question quand
ils arrivent au début c'est la barrière
de la langue parce que si on vient pour
le travail on n'a pas forcément eu le
temps d'apprendre l'allemand donc on est
les allemands parlent très bien en
anglais aussi voilà il parle anglais
beaucoup parlent français aussi mais
quand vous arrivez à des choses plus
importantes comme s'inscrire pour
l'école ou le jardin d'enfants où aller
chez le médecin remplir des formulaires
ça devient un peu compliqué ils sont pas
toujours tous en anglais et là on est là
pour les aider par exemple au sein de
votre association vous organisez
également plusieurs activités comme
visiter les musées de la vie comme faire
des activités sportives ou même des
soirées jeux qui participent à ces
activités est-ce qu'il y a des Allemands
aussi ou uniquement des Français alors
tout ce qui peuvent parler français sont
les bienvenus alors pas forcément des
Allemands puisque c'est une ville
internationale mais voilà le but est
qu'on parle français ensemble donc les
Allemands sont toujours les bienvenus et
c'est très intéressant pour nous pour
eux aussi puisque une langue ça prend
tous les jours et ils apprennent avec
nous et nous on apprend de aussi et on
fait des soirées jeux mais on fait aussi
des coins cuisine et des choses ou on
papote c'est pour tous les âges aussi
c'est important de mixer les générations
entre elles
important pour nous moi je vous avoue
j'ai commencé à venir au carrefour un
oeuvre-accueil quand mes enfants sont
nés parce que j'étais la seule à leur
parler français il me fallait du monde
pour m'aider et depuis mes enfants
parlent français avec d'autres Français
d'un vrai et c'est important pour vous
de transmettre aussi cette amitié
franco-allemande dont on parle si
souvent oui c'est très important pour
pour moi pour ma famille pour t'aider
français qui sont là on aime partager
nos valeurs françaises et allemande on
fait la même chose quand on est en
France ou à Rouen et pour terminer
Laurence Belland venir vivre ici c'est
forcément ce plonger dans la culture
allemande est-ce que la vie est très
différente ici par rapport à la France
par rapport à Rouen en Normandie par
exemple oui je pense elle est différente
je pense que le plus difficile pour les
Français c'est s'adapter à la discipline
allemande mais quand on vient on le sait
c'est connu et on a des moments un petit
peu difficiles mais on s'adapte et ça
fonctionne puisque